los juegos de lucha Siempre han sido uno
de mis géneros favoritos y desde muy
pequeño he jugado un montón de ellos
vamos aquí no le gusta romperse la cara
con bichos super mamadísimos
pero pocos juegos tan brutales y
divertidos como Def young Five for New
York un juego que destacó de los demás
por ser más violento y realista que los
otros aquí no tendrás Ninja super
poderosos o bichos raros peleando solo
raperos muy enojados dispuestos a
hacerse [__] es decir en qué otro
juego pues partirle la madre a Snoop
Dogg al ritmo de sus canciones
[Música]
si me conocen bien y a mi serie de
curiosidades saben que tengo una
fascinación por tomar juegos de mi
infancia que son buenísimos pero de los
que nadie habla y dedicarles un merecido
vídeo y ahora es el turno de defyang mi
turno
han pasado años desde la última vez que
toque este juego pero hace poco me
encontraba pensando en qué videojuego
sería el siguiente en tener su propio
vídeo y me acordé de este monumento de
juego y no había manera en que no le
dedicara un vídeo así que ponte cómodo Y
Acompáñame a ver 10 curiosidades
secretos y detalles de Def jump fire for
New York
es este
tuvo que doler el primer juego de esta
saga se llamó Def Jam Vendetta que al
ver el éxito que tuvo cuando estaban
creando las secuela estuvieron a punto
de darle el súper original nombre de
Jean Vendetta 2
demonios Eres realmente un genio al
parecer el inmenso Ingenio y creatividad
de los desarrolladores no les alcanzó
para pensar en un nombre mejor Incluso
en el menú inicial se puede ver el logo
original del juego
afortunadamente a mitad de desarrollo le
pusieron el nombre que ya todos
conocemos como dato extra al
personalizar a tu jugador puedes
encontrar un collar con el logo del
primer juego
el juego original de Vendetta era un
juego un poco distinto se daban igual en
la madre pero era un juego más enfocado
en la lucha libre Así que para hacer a
este juego algo único dejaron atrás esa
idea y lo hicieron un juego mucho más
callejero con peleas más brutales y
escenarios más improvisados incluso
diseñaron al público para que sea más
agresivo de manera que durante la pelea
te puedan pasar armas ayudarte con
algunas llaves o incluso golpeándote
ellos mismos con un palo
el juego tiene varias colaboraciones muy
sutiles pero efectivas pues por ejemplo
a la hora de personalizar a tu poderoso
luchador puedes encontrar zapatillas
Jordan o Reebok y en varios escenarios
encontrarás publicidad pegada en las
paredes un detalle bastante genial es
que a medida que tu personaje es
golpeado el daño se ve reflejado en su
rostro si ganas la pelea sin que te
toquen un solo pelo tu personaje
terminará ileso Pero si te magullan
bastante tu personaje tendrá rasguños
sangre y moretones en el rostro lo
extraño Es que esto sólo sucede con los
hombres los personajes femeninos no
tienen esta característica
hombres y que viva el patriarcado que
el traje de Pin que usa Snoop Dogg en la
cinemáticas del juego originalmente iba
a ser usable en las peleas pero debido a
que ocasionaba varios errores y glitches
con las texturas desecharon la idea la
historia del juego gira en torno a dos
pandillas queriéndose acercarnitas la
una a la otra y durante la creación del
juego se tenía la idea de que casi al
final de la historia se hiciera una
pelea todos contra todos con más de ocho
personajes al tiempo partiéndose la cara
pero por las limitaciones de las
consolas no se pudo hacer después del
éxito del juego la saga se fue al [__]
pues su siguiente juego Def Jam icon fue
una [__] tenía conceptos interesantes
como usar la música en las peleas pero
fueron implementados de manera tan mala
que terminó siendo uno de los peores
juegos de peleas que existen el juego
fue tan criminalmente malo que hizo que
la franquicia cambiara de rumbo y en
2010 salió a la venta el juego Def Jam
Rockstar una extraña especie de juego de
ritmo Pero de igual manera fue un asco y
debido a los fracasos de sus más
recientes juegos actualmente la
franquicia se encuentra Tres metros bajo
tierra
en su momento muchos se preguntaron por
qué no habían incluido a otro raperos
conocidos de la época en el juego donde
estaba skill Eminem donde demonios
estaba Doctor Dre la respuesta la
encontré creando Este vídeo Pues resulta
que defyang es en realidad una disquera
Yo pensé que era un hombre que le habían
puesto lo [__] al juego pero no es
una disquera que se aventuró a hacer
videojuegos y si no incluyeron a ciertos
raperos fue porque no consiguieron los
derechos para incluir su imagen en el
juego
este juego fue tan bueno que tuvo varias
versiones para distintas consolas Tuvo
una versión para celulares que es
horrible y también una para PSP que se
llamaba de takeover esta versión a pesar
de tener peores gráficos tenía algún
contenido y mecánicas extra podías
golpear a tus enemigos en el suelo y
había algunos movimientos exclusivos de
esta versión
justo al inicio del juego después de que
creas a tu personaje en una cinemática
se puede ver a dos de los personajes
jugando este mismo juego
Pero además de eso un detalle genial es
que los controles que sostienen cambian
dependiendo de Qué versión estás Jugando
PlayStation 2
GameCube o Xbox
[Música]
a pesar de que la saga está bien pero
bien muerta el primero de agosto de 2018
la cuenta de Twitter de defyang publicó
una imagen que decía Escoge una ciudad y
tenía varias opciones de logo como
preguntando a la gente en donde quieren
que se ambiente un nuevo juego lo que
quiere decir que sus creadores aún le
tienen fe a la saga y están dispuestos a
revivir los juegos
no me
Ojalá hubiera más datos que pudiera
contarte pero eso es todo lo que hay es
una verdadera pena que este juego a
pesar de ser todo un éxito no pudo
salvar a su saga y ahora este más que
muerta
Mortal Kombat Bloody Roar y otros pocos
es uno de los juegos de lucha que más he
disfrutado Y aunque es poco probable aún
Espero que lo puedan traer de vuelta
aunque sea con una pequeña
remasterización sé que no soy el único
que pudo probar este juegazo así que
quiero ver en los comentarios Cuántos de
ustedes aún recuerdan a Def Jam hasta la
próxima
[Música]